هي ذات التطورات عبد القادر فيما يتعلق في
التطورات الميدانيه ما زلنا في منطقه
خانيونس تحديدا في المناطق الشرقيه
للمدينه وللمحافظات ايضا باكملها نستمع
الى اصوات الرشاشات الثقيله والمختلفه
الاعيره تنطلق بشكل متقطع وفي اكثر من
محور على اكثر من في اكثر من منطقه ايضا
وهذا
يعني بانه هناك اشتباكات تندلع بين حين
واخر بين المقاومين الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومعروف عبد القادر بانه خلال
ساعات الليل على وجه الخصوص تقوم قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بمحاوله تكثيف
انشطتها فيما يتعلق بالتوغل او زياده
التوغل توسعه نطاق مناطق تمركز الاليات
الاسرائيليه والقيام ببعض المهام داخل
الاحياء وبالتالي تقوم قوم باطلاق وابل
كثيف من الرصاص من انطلاقا من الرشاشات
الموجوده في على الدبابات الاسرائيليه
فيما تنشر اعدادا كبيره من الطائرات
المسيره صغيره الحجم المعروفه باكواد
كابتر في الاجواء وبالتالي تراقب اي متحرك
في الشوارع وفي المناطق خصوصا التي تج
تقوم فيها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باعتداءات او اعمال تقوم بها في هذه
المناطق فضلا عن المناطق الاخرى التي ايضا
تقوم هذه الطائرات الاسرائيليه برصد ما
يجري فيها لا سما في المناطق الغربيه
لمدينه خان يونس الاشتباكات ما تزال
مستمره وذلك جنبا الى جنب مع قصف مدفعي
بشكل متقطع على بعض المناطق ونحن ما زلنا
نستمع الى اصوات بعض الانفجارات في هذه
المناطق القريبه نسبيا من مجمع ناصر الطبي
الذي نتواجد به لكن كل هذا يجري في اطار
استمرار مسلسل الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
التي تنفذه المقاتلات الحربيه وايضا
المسيرات
الاسرائيليه التي يعج بها سماء قطاع غزه
اخر الغارات كانت تلك التي استهدفت منزلين
و قطعه ارض ايضا تضم نازحين فلسطينيين
لجوا الى هذه المنطقه في محيط المستشفى
الاوروبي الى الجنوب الشرقي من محافظه
خانيونس وهذه غاره كانت من بين الغارات
الاعنف والاكثر دمويه هذا اليوم وبالتالي
وصل عدد الشهداء الى 25 شهيدا وعشرات
الجرحى الذين سقطوا خلال هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه سبقها في محافظه خانيونس ايضا
غارتين اثنتين على مقربه من المجمع ناصر
الطبي استهدفت المسيرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه منزلا كان فيه مجموعه من
المواطنين الفلسطينيين الامر الذي ادى الى
استشهاد خمسه واصابه اخرين فيما استهدفت
طائرات اخرى منطقه في غرب مدينه خانيونس
كان يتجمع فيها بعض الصبيا والاطفال
والمواطنين بحيث انه مكان تعج فيه الحركه
المواطنين في هذه المنطقه الامر الذي ادى
الى استشهاد اربعه مواطنين واصابه اخرين
بطبيعه الحال في محافظه رفح كانت هناك
ايضا سلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه على
منزلين ومسجد وهو الامر الذي ادى الى سقوط
عدد كبير من الشهداء والجرحى ضمن استمرار
الغارات الاسرائيليه بما في ذلك سياسه
الاحزمه الناريه التي استهدفت احد
المربعات السكنيه وتحديدا في منزل واحد
لكن المربع باكمله اصيب باضرار كبيره جراء
هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه المتتاليه التي
استهدفت هذا المنزل في محيط المستشفى
الكويتي في رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه هذا الامر
يعني لا يختلف كثيرا عن مناطق شمال قطاع
غزه كما يصنفها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تحديدا مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع اللتان ما
تزال تشهدان عمليات لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليات تصفيه للمواطنين
الفلسطينيين جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
اليومين الماضيين وحتى هذا اليوم يقوم بعم
عمليات دهم لبعض المنازل وتكثيف لعملياته
العسكريه سواء من حيث القصف المدفعي او
القصف بالغارات او حتى بالده للمنازل في
مناطق كانت نسبيا الى حد ما هي مناطق لم
يشملها القصف بشكل كبير مثل منطقه حي
الدرج ومنطقه الصحابه وهذه المناطق التي
واضح بان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اصبح
يكثف عملياته في قلب هذه المناطق ويقوم
بدهم المنازل حتى التي لم تقصف ويقوم بشن
عمليات اعتقال ومن ثم تصفيه بحق ساكني هذه
المنازل كما جاء على لسان شهود عيان كثر
في اكثر من عماره واكثر من بنايه سكنيه في
هذه المناطق